Dean Martin has not appeared at the
Academy Awards for 13 years the only way
we got Dean here tonight was to put him
in a tux while he was asleep and tell
him he was going to a ruse Ruth Buzzi
roast see I make those mistakes
occasionally for the translators who are
doing this for the foreign countries but
when Dean heard who his real
co-presenter was he woke up immediately
this matchup was made in heaven to
present the award for best scoring Dean
Martin and Raquel Welch
well I'll relay eight to five only to
you people were looking at me
well that hey we're lucky is written in
Caucasian Oh what are you doing I don't
know what I'm doing well I sure I'm glad
we're giving this award well so am i
yeah for outstanding original score
that's the one thing I really know
something about what scoring how music
music I think we got it reversed yeah
well anywhere there's an old cliche that
says the best musical score for a film
is one that you don't even hear to which
the late Mack Steiner once replied if
you don't hear it what the hell good is
it you should that it is one I know all
right
this year's nominee
you didn't tell me that was gonna happen
there's the hell out of me as it is up
here this year's nominees for
outstanding original score have all been
worth hearing Dean let's listen to him
there they are
jerry goldsmith for the boys from Brazil
in your mother for four days of heaven
Dave Grusin for heaven can wait
giorgio moroder
for Midnight Express
John Williams for Superman oh and the
winner is Wow
the winner is Giorgio Moroder
thank you very much Neil Bogart Joyce
Bogut and Peter Guber for giving me the
chance to start in this new beautiful
feel that this is my first score thank
you very much to the producers to the
first goal yes thank you to the
producers David Puttnam and Alan
Marshall and thank you to to the
director Alan Park
that was good I might settle come all
that time together gore well ii hmm
you're my this is getting very dicey the
second award in the music category is
for outstanding adaptation score and the
nominees are the Buddy Holly story
adaptation score by Joe Renzetti yeah
and pretty baby had a patient score by
Jerry Wexler
The Wiz adaptations score back quincy
jones and the winner is upside down Oh
Joe Renzetti for the Buddy Holly story
I'd like to playing some very talented
men men with foresight courage the
producer mr. Fred Bauer the director
Steve rash very skilled and patient man
mr. ed Cohen and the actors who don't
know for you kind ladies and gentlemen
no actually played and sung on camera
with 24-track recording and we did it
and thank you all
racquel that is a lovely outfit although
I don't believe you will be invited to
dinner by the ayatollah khomeini